emile et atteint la demi heure au final
c'est une maladie qui est dégénérative
qui fait que c'est une musique mort à
force qui grandit si paralyse de plus en
plus en grandissant l'amyotrophie
spinale l'asm a est une maladie
génétique rare
une personne sur 6000 en est atteinte
autour de 150 au québec est mêlé
gravement atteints il a toute sa tête
mais son corps refuse de le suivre mais
là besoin qu'on s'aligne quand l'aide à
respirer avec un des papes quand on voit
le type de gavage juste my il peut pas
manger par lui-même
photo de préparer il faut l'aider à tout
signe pour le tourner il faut tout faire
pour lui il existe une seule médicaments
pour traiter l'asm a le spin raza la
compagnie biogen qui permet de se doper
la progression de la maladie
sur le web on trouve des dizaines de
vidéos qui montrent les progrès
accomplis par de jeunes patients sousse
pedraza sans crier au miracle
on peut parler d'un médicament
exceptionnel qui fait la différence
le canada a d'ailleurs approuvé son
utilisation en 2017 et québec le
rembourse depuis septembre mais
seulement pour les cas de sm a de type 1
les plus graves pour les types 2 3 et 4
pas de remboursement or emile est un cas
de type 2 ans pas de la même maladie
quelques on parle d'un type c'est pas de
maladies différentes ces gens
s'installent plus sévère de la maladie
mais ils vont tout semblait de toute
façon c'est tout dégénératif le problème
du spin reza c'est son prix environ 700
mille dollars la première année 350
mille dollars
les années suivantes pourtant même si
l'un des médicaments les plus chers au
monde l'espère asa et présence m'a
remboursé dans plus d'une quarantaine de
pays
on vient finalement vraiment joué sur la
notion de ses coûts de prise une vie
humaine et le prix d'une vie humaine
dans nos sociétés est quelque chose
d'extrêmement élevé on considère que ça
ça vaut la peine d'investir pour sauver
les gens dans la mesure où médicaments
marche et où il sauve potentiellement la
vie des gens la compagnie peut jouer
très très très fortement sur les prix
élevé est la gr ont reçu dans leur
poussette
monsieur desfossés a remué ciel et terre
pour que son fils liam un cas de sm à
deux types qu'on puisse être traitée ou
spinoza
il a eu gain de cause ça fait une
différence pour lui physiquement mais
aussi moralement psychologiquement c'est
c'est énorme
ne plus avoir l'épée de damoclès d'une
maladie dégénérative la bataille de yann
défaut ci est loin d'être terminée il
veut maintenant forcé le système de
santé à mettre tous ses citoyens sur un
pied d'égalité en moyenne ce genre de
médicament à la boe fixé cible ou pas
c'est un canadien 4 1 après
l'autorisation de santé canada ce qui
est anormal surtout dans un cas de
maladie dégénérative graves comme ça le
père de liam a donc cogner à la porte de
la commission des droits de la personne
puis à celle du protecteur du citoyen il
songe même où tribunaux on ne veut pas
que ça soit réglé au cas par cas comme
ça parce qu'après ça qu'un santé canada
va autoriser les médicaments pour un
mort kyo pour l'ess est là pour la
dystrophie musculaire de duchenne
tous ces communes et taylor vont
exactement le même problème que nous son
objectif est ambitieux il existe plus de
5000 maladies rares la capacité de payer
des étapes est limité et celle de
négocier avec une entreprise qui détient
un monopole l'est tout autant
c'est certain que si tous les pays
établissent que tel médicament ne
rentrera pas sur leur marché parce qu'il
est considéré comme inaccessible la
compagnie va baisser son prix puisque
aucune compagnie est intéressé à avoir
un médicament même s'ils fonctionnent
qu'elle ne va nulle part
maintenant est-ce qu ici aiguisé
suffisamment de cohérence au niveau
international pour qu'on voie ça se
produire à l'heure actuelle c'est peu
probable
j'ai aussi trouvé sur la mer des 1000
espère que le québec révisera bientôt sa
position sur le spi nasa ont fait ce
côté 2.3 millions à date entre et
services de santé à la population
québécoise
alors moi j'estime que le
j'estime que le bénéficiaire mais pour
elle comme pour plusieurs familles le
temps presse pour emile c'est qu'on voit
ses capacités diminuer qu'on voit qu'on
a des amis que eux mêmes plus ferme m de
type erp qui sont en train de le
dépasser qui se met debout qui marche
qui font du tri c'est qui est mon fils
lambert respirer ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal